I apologize for the lack of YouTube
videos recently I'm still a little bit
burnt out but I'm doing my best
[Music]
okay let's go we played him twice
actually so
I'm not going to play repeat opponents
too many times unless there's nobody
else to play oh my God chess Meister 2
24 31. that's a pretty darn High rating
well let's go
24 31 let's go Knight F6
and obviously against the player this
high rated this is the highest rated
player we've faced in the speed run ever
so I have to play my main repertoire
that I can't Dicker around here
which means we're gonna play The King's
Indian
and our opponent is trotting out the
fianchetto variation which is one of the
most reputable and positionally
dangerous responses against the king's
Indian of course it's the line where
white plays G3 and fiancutters their
King side Bishop and then typically
Castle's King side now so far we have
not committed to a king's Indian we
commit to a king's Indian when we push
the d-pawn up to D6 we can also play
this in a grunfeld fashion we can castle
and push D5 or we can play this in a
grunefeld slav fashion and this is the
recommendation of a lot of sort of
modern day chess literature which is to
play C6 and then D5 and that line does
equalize there's no doubt about that but
it's more fun and more in the spirit of
my repertoire to play this in a more
traditional King's Indian fashion which
is why we play D6
and here we reach a very wide
theoretical Crossroads black has a
million different setups against the
fianchetto variation and I would say
that these setups are broadly divided
into three categories there are setups
where black prepares E5 this is what
we're going to play in this game because
this is the most traditional and Kings
indian-esque variation there are setups
that involve playing the move C5 this is
what gawaine Jones recommends in his
chessable course This lends the flavor a
more benoni uh lends the game more
benoni flavor then there are systems
where you play neither E5 nor C5 at
least not immediately you can play C6
um you can play Bishop F5 you can play
Knight C6 and A6 which is the Pono
variation one of the main lines against
the fiancato so there's a staggering
number of variations and they're all
pretty decent but we're going to choose
the one that I've played for the longest
time and that's Knight B to D7 and
quickly pushing E5 now White's main
response is to strike back in the center
with E4 and that's what our opponent
plays and here I've played two different
variations in my chess career the first
is e takes D4 a trading off in the
center immediately then paying a visit
to C5 with the Knight and putting
pressure on this you could think of it
as a maruti bind this is not a maruti
binder for specifically to The Struck
structure that occurs in the accelerated
Dragon but you can think of the pawns on
e4 and C4 as kind of a morosi bind like
construction and this position does
resemble an accelerated dragon in that
after he takes D4 black is cramped and
white is a big space Advantage but black
applies long lasting pressure to White
Center and if white doesn't handle the
position with great care then White
Center can collapse but in this game I'd
like to play a second line and this is
an older Line This is what I used to
play over the board when I was you know
up until International Master Level and
I still play this almost exclusively in
Blitz because it's an incredibly tricky
line and it's a line that often slips
through the cracks of even very
experienced uh ifian Kettle players so
you start with the move C6
and again if you've watched my stream
then you've probably seen me play this
line the point of the line is to bring
the queen out to A5 I might have even
had this in a speedrun game at some
point
so you know if if memory serves me right
but this line is incredibly tricky and
our opponent already demonstrates very
very good knowledge of this system the
move Bishop E3 is the sort of new
recommendation
um as far as I know this is what like
the top Grandmasters play nowadays the
old move which almost everybody played
up until a year ago was rookie one and
I'll give you the lowdown on this line
after the game I'll give you some
theoretical overview and I'll show some
cool traps after Bishop E3 we're
supposed to release the tension with e
takes D4 this is theory so I'm not
explaining these moves uh deeply I'm
just making them because they're the
theoretical moves at this point we
discharge the tension in the center and
the reason we do it I think at this
precise moment
is because white is already prepared to
push D5 and close the center down and
the bishop on E3 is very harmoniously
placed so this is our sort of last
opportunity to exchange the pawns before
white closes the center and white is at
a further Crossroads there's Bishop
takes D4 and there's the more
traditional recapture which is of course
Knight takes D4 most of the time when
black plays Edie white doesn't even have
the option if Bishop takes D4 so most
players who are not as experienced kind
of automatically play Knight 64. clearly
our opponent realized that there's a
choice to be made here and make no
mistake like if you run this through the
computer yeah white is better but white
has to demonstrate tremendous precision
as is true in most Kings Indian lines in
order to prove that advantage and from
the point of view of a rapid game black
has a lot of easy moves black has a lot
of ways to create threats and if black
seizes the initiative you know what
happens in a king's Indian where black
has the initiative so I really really
believe in this line I mean hopefully
I'll be able to demonstrate it against a
really really strong player our opponent
is thinking
I'm pretty sure you have this in a
previous speedrun game since soup the
Sailor I'm pretty sure of that too maybe
even in this speedrun although I don't
remember when I feel like I have
definitely played this queen A5
variation
um before
so if if you remember that game you can
let me know but it doesn't really matter
um it's been I think a sufficient amount
of time has passed so our opponent plays
The Annoying move I didn't want to say
what the what the annoying move was just
in case but Bishop takes D4 is the move
I really dislike playing against
the reason is that your standard
response will be Knight E5 but in
response to 95 white has a tactic and
this tactic just kills the line 95 is
almost a decisive mistake Believe It or
Not does anybody know what the idea is
against Knight E5 and that is why we
have to keep this Knight on D7 for the
time being if we play 95 we walk into
what do we walk into
it's a very unusual tactical idea very
unusual
extremely yes C5 white undermines the
Knight with C5 and typically you're just
able to take on F3 but white recaptures
with the queen and the Knight on F6 is
suddenly hanging right that's the power
of recapturing with the bishop so Knight
E5 walks into C5 and that is why we want
to make a more flexible move so let's
make let's sort of pick the low-hanging
fruit and start with rookie 8 which is a
move that will not harm our position
that is for sure
let's wait for white to kind of show his
cards and then we'll make a more
substantive decision about how to
position our pieces it'll it's possible
that our Queen on A5 has done its job
and should drop back to C7 in order to
make 95 possible because we can't keep
this Knight on D7 forever it blocks the
bishop on C8 and it causes our position
to be very cramped we of course can
deploy the Knight to C5 but I like that
a lot less in this position for a couple
of reasons one of which is that with the
queen on A5 and the Knight on C5
obviously white has like a three before
ideas but also Knight C5 just seems very
flimsy maybe white can push in the
center with E5 and white can very easily
defend the E4 Pawn so while Knight C5
might be tempting to attack the E4 Pawn
I really really think the Knight is
better positioned on E5 in this line and
these are the sorts of things that you
just feel right when you play a line
many times you make a lot of mistakes
and at some point you start developing a
finer understanding of where the pieces
belong and it can't always be explained
verbally like step by step like this is
exactly why this piece goes here and
that piece goes there a lot of it has to
do with feel okay so rookie one and I do
think we should drop our Queen back to
C7 because Knight E5 still allows C5
um and the Queen on A5 is kind of
neither here nor there
so I'm I'm very much inclined to play
Queen C7 and then jump out to E5 with
our Knight
we've got other ways that we can
maneuver around the
you know the hurdles we can play Knight
f8 and Knight E6 kind of a RI Lopez
style idea but this to me seems a lot
more King's indian-esque in nature let's
go Knights let's go queen queen C7 yeah
cramped position for sure cramped
position but a very solid position
classic King's Indian situation
what was the idea a lot of people are
asking what was the idea of Queen A5 I
will explain that after the game it's
harder to see it because of what our
opponent played which is Bishop E3
if our opponent had played the main move
which is rookie one then I think you
would have really understood the value
of this queen sometimes it can swing
over to H5 that's like one easy thing to
to understand and the other like broad
thing is that it aims at the Knight on
C3 so the move B3 is a very useful move
for white in these positions to defend
the C4 Pawn with the queen on A5 B3 is
not possible and it's actually a very
common blunder at lower levels I've even
beaten title players like this they play
B3 automatically without realizing that
the Knight is now hanging so in many
situations when the C4 Pawn is attacked
from B6 or E5 it's actually very hard to
defend that pawn adequately if you've
got if you don't have the ability to
play B3
okay Queen C2 well our opponent
continues to improve his position
I think that we should do the same and
we should probably follow through on our
plan and play 95. okay I think black is
a pretty decent position here I think
white has a very powerful move here
super Advanced move we'll see if our
opponent finds it this is a very
Advanced move
I think most people who look at this
position
and most people would take on E5 but
generally that trade favors black and
the reason is really simple I've talked
about this at length before when you get
the quote-unquote symmetrical Pawn
structure in the king's Indian it's
actually not symmetrical at all and the
chief difference is that White's got
pawns on C4 and E4 so why does a big big
weakness on the D4 Square which really
comes out in the event that black plays
D takes E5 black on the other hand has
this Pawn on C6 which is restricting the
Knight on C3 so Knight takes E5 is a
positional mistake here in my opinion
and I've won a lot of games in that
structure because ultimately you just
shuttle your knight around to D4 and R4
and of course plays the advanced move I
had no doubt in my mind
and now we reach a I think a very
important position so 92 drops the
Knight away and protects C4 clearly it's
also preparing the move F4 now F4 is not
the end of the world it sends our Knight
back to D7 but in the king's Indian you
have to be totally comfortable moving
pieces back and forth with that said I
don't want to allow up for because I
really really do I want to try to
entrench and establish this Knight on E5
if at all possible so we ask ourselves
the question is it possible to stop F4
and I actually think it is we can make a
positionally risky move this is a risky
move it can it has its drawbacks but
this is what the Kings Indian is all
about you have to know and feel the
situations in which such moves are
necessary what are we talking about here
this move does not physically prevent F4
but it discourages it I'm talking about
the move G5 this in and of itself is a
construction that you might find
familiar like you put a knight on E5 and
then you put a pawn two squares away you
do this if you translate this to the
right side of the board in the king's
Indian you play Knight C5 and then A5
it's the same exact principle if white
plays F4 now my idea is to trade once on
F4 and drop the Knight back to G6 to put
more pressure on the F4 Pawn then the
situation gets a lot more Tactical
which is really to my liking I feel like
R king is a little bit safer than
White's in that position
thank you red calamity
all right
so we're trying to also the move G5 has
opened up the G6 Square for the Knight
so Knight G6 is only a move made
possible by the push of the pawn why am
I not more worried about the weakness
that we create first of all this is less
drastic of a weakening move than it may
appear because you know we still have
our fianchetto Bishop our King is still
safe it's not like we play G5 and the
world ends yes it's a risky move
positionally also because we weaken the
F5 Square so oftentimes you will see
white immediately burying the Knight
over to E3 but the F5 square is also
guarded by our light squared Bishop so
I'm not
too worried about an outpost on F5 in
the near future it's kind of hard for
white to find a move here this is what I
find to be the case in the fianchetto
variation white just burns a ton of time
black is worse objectively cramped yes
but sometimes Black's play is just more
clearly defined
okay so our opponent has spent close to
half their time and it's only move 14.
I'm already keeping a close eye on
White's clock
what's our next move going to be well
we've got a couple of
you know again I call this low-hanging
fruit
by which I refer to moves that you you
know that these moves are not going to
hurt your position so what are like the
easy things that we can do well first of
all we can develop this bishop but we
need to be mindful of where we develop
it I think most people would be tempted
by Bishop E6 but after Bishop E6 white
can play B3 and that's not the issue the
issue is that subsequently when white
plays the move F4 we're in trouble
because we cannot play Knight G6 white
pushes F5 forking our Bishop in our
Knight so actually it might be a better
idea to play the more modest move Bishop
to D7 alright so that F4 could still be
met after the preliminary exchange with
the move Knight G6
what other moves can we considered well
we actually can play H5 and try to go G4
this is a more advanced and involved
plan because it weakens more of our King
side but if we can play the moves H5 and
G4 what we do is create a essentially
lifetime bind on the king side because
then any time that white will try to
play F4 we will take onpassant and
weaken whites kingside tremendously so
that's a more you know plan that is
involved with more risk in terms of
small improving moves other than Bishop
D7 I don't see all that much that we can
do
B3 okay so B3 gives us a pretty wide
Choice our opponent just kind of passing
the move I really like the plan of H5
and G4 and you might ask well can we
play G4 immediately the answer is no
because then white plays H takes G4 and
the whole purpose of that move is
defeated we're not actually stopping
white from playing F4
so really I think the choice is between
Bishop D7 and H5 and as a
self-respecting king's Indian player I
almost always
err on the side of the more you know the
riskier the more interesting move the
move that's more challenging and I think
H5 is a very challenging move especially
in light of White's clock situation
because our opponent will now see that
we want to go G4 what does that mean
well it means he's going to start
calculating F4 because F4 is a serious
candidate move and this might be White's
last chance to play that move because
after we play G4 we will get that bind
in place
I like H5 I think it's a I think it's a
very testing move okay less than seven
minutes now for our opponent not to get
too transfixed on the clock but it is a
very important factor uh in any position
and now that we've reached this higher
level in the speed run
you know I'm I'm
telling you exactly the sorts of things
that I would focus on in a real rapid
game
and in a real rapid game I would already
be like pretty much obsessed with
White's clock and making moves that are
simultaneously healthy but also give
white a big choice
okay I I hate it when people pretend
that you know you're not supposed to
talk about the clock because it's not a
legitimate part of the game it
absolutely is and knowing how to handle
both your and your opponent's clock will
give you massive massive rating bonuses
okay
we're waiting for our opponent's
response here
obviously he's going to start playing a
lot faster in just a couple moves here I
would end I would imagine
yeah so
Rook a D1 yeah this is what I thought uh
what would do our opponent is just sort
of making straightforward improving
moves let's just make sure that G4 is
the best that we can do of course we can
also play the move H4 and the move H4 is
a very sensible candidate move actually
it might be worth spending a little bit
more time contemplating this move than
it may appear
what's so great about the move H4 well
H4 is a classic positional idea you are
trying to lure white into playing G4 and
if white plays G4 then again the move F4
is virtually impossible to achieve we
get this big big bind on the dark
squares in the center so H4 very much
possible white can take and play F4 but
that leads us to once again serious
complications on the king side that I
think might favor black but I'm not sure
I mean that that is a very complicated
position
so we can go G4 as originally planned we
can do neither we can play Bishop D7
here and kick the can down the road
right since we're not too worried about
white playing F4
um
this is a hard hard a hard decision
but my inclination is to play G4 my
heavy inclination is to play G4
but the move G4 is also associated with
positional risk because it weakens for
example the F4 Square so one thing that
white could do is shutter shuttle this
Knight around to F4 not that that's such
a big huge cataclysmic square but still
we should be mindful of the squares that
we're weakening when we push our pawns
like this okay let's go G4
this just I feel like this has to be the
move this is this is principled it's
what we've been building up toward and
it would be a big relief if we didn't
constantly have to worry about the
prospect of f4
okay HG
obviously we play HG the white buys
himself a Tempo but I would draw your
attention to the fact that the H file is
now open
and we're not as far away as it may
appear from exploiting that I think
we're actually like three or four moves
away from being able to pick up on that
H file we can play something like Bishop
H6 King G7 and Rook h8 bang now when a
rook gets to h8 it's not Checkmate but
at least we create the potential
preconditions for tactics on the H file
we can even consider King H7 King G6 and
Rook h8 but I would rule that out on the
basis of this Knight maneuver to F4
which will send our King right back to
H7
and so that's why it's so important to
constantly keep in your mind a list of
the squares that you're weakening when
you when you play a lot with your pawns
because that helps you rule out certain
options like okay I know that F4 is a
weakness so I need to be mindful of this
maneuver I know that F5 is weak is a
maneuver there we go 92. okay now things
are getting spicy our opponent walking
around to F4 let's let's think for a
second
so I guess one question is do we want to
prevent or try to discourage Knight F4
or do we not care if we don't care then
we can play Bishop H6 and keep going
with our plan if we do care one thing we
can consider is the move Knight to H5
and I actually really like the look of
Knight H5 because it's not easy to see
how Knight H5 actually stops Knight F4
and it doesn't white can still play
Knight F4
but after Knight takes F4 G takes F4
Knight G6 we trade the Bishops and
White's got this long lasting weakness
on F4 that's actually going to be I
think really hard to defend the position
there gets super spicy but maybe it's a
little bit on the dubious side
okay I'm gonna think some more ah
I've come up with another interesting
idea
I've come up with another very
interesting idea this one is really cute
what if we go not Knight H5 but Knight
to H7 what if we try not H7 here I'm
looking at this F3 square and I really
would like to increase our bind over
these light squares that we have
garnered by pushing the pawn to G4
and it makes sense I think to bring this
Knight around to G5
so that it can jump into F3 jump into H3
and in general just crab legs on the
king side
it's got its drawbacks like the Knight
on G5 is not stable it can be pretty
easily attacked for instance with
White's Bishop but I think in light of
White's clock situation we should give
this move a shot Knight H7
the best move in chess
okay Bishop E3 preventing Knight G5 but
I saw that and I thought we could
reinforce that with Queen E7 or Bishop
Bishop F6
let's think about this for a little
while longer because now white actually
might be preparing Knight to D4
followed by Knight F5 we should keep
track of that idea as we devise our next
move
okay so the the options here are to play
Bishop F6 Queen E7 everything to prepare
an ig5
okay I need to think in silence for a
bit here
this is an important position rookie 6
is also interesting by the way oh
why hmm I could spend 30 minutes on this
position
which I'm not going to do don't worry
okay
I'm gonna go with my initial idea we're
gonna go Queen E7 here we're gonna go
Queen E7
and this is I think the most obvious
move right you're bringing the queen
from C7 to E7 where it is a little bit
more equipped to join the action on the
king side but the main idea is to
prepare an ig5 now you might look and
say well I don't understand why Knight
G5 is even on our plate here because
white can play Bishop takes G5 but the
trade of the bishop for the Knight gives
us a monopoly over the dark squares
right then our Bishop on G7 is going to
be really happy now this is what I was
worried about this was an incredible
maneuver by White Knight two Bishop E3
and Knight C4 way over my head to be
honest but okay we're gonna deal with
that
I'm going to deal with it by trying to
adopt an interesting defensive setup
here's what I was thinking we might do
here's what I was thinking we might do I
think that we should go
I think we should go Queen F6 here just
getting the queen onto its optimal
Square
getting the queen to its optimal Square
I'm expecting white to play Knight F5
here right and complete his maneuver
and after Knight F5 we should resist
with every fiber of our being the
temptation to play Bishop takes F5 I
think that would be a serious positional
mistake because following e takes F5 not
only have we given up uh light squared
bishop and our whole play on the king
side is predicated on light Square
control so we need this bishop for
future use but in addition more
importantly after Knight F5 Bishop F5 EF
white gets this juicy E4 Square for his
other Knight then the D6 Pawn will
collapse and then our whole position
collapses so it's so important this Pawn
on e4 is what's saving our life is all
of White's pieces want that square for
themselves
so after Knight F5 we're gonna drop our
Bishop back to f8 in order to lend an
additional Defender to this D6 pawn and
I know it looks really awkward
but I actually think it's a very
watertight defensive construction Rook
F1 is not scary unless our opponent is
preparing F4
which I kind of assumed was not
achievable but I guess it is
so we can play Knight G5 we can also try
to throw in Bishop H6 and trade the dark
squid Bishops which as I discussed was a
good idea positionally but maybe bishop
H6 fails tactically I don't know
again need to think in silence for a bit
because this gets super complicated
I like the look of Bishop H6
from a positional standpoint but it's
also risky because you give up the
king's Indian Bishop which is also a
defensive
Maverick in such positions
really really hard decisions here that
our opponent is making us take yeah I
honestly don't know whether we should
play Bishop H6 or not my positional
sense is telling me yes but tactically
I'd be really scared of our King safety
I think the X Factor here might be
White's clock I'm gonna make a bet that
white does not have enough time to
punish us for the move Bishop H6
well of course the guy's 2400 he's he's
probably like strong Master Level IRL
so this is with the black it's not going
to be an easy game I'm not wasn't
expecting one I was not expecting an
easy game
I think both of our sets of pieces are
very nicely placed this has been a high
level maneuvering game I'm proud of the
way that I played on the king side and
we are just like a couple steps away
from really instituting a an Unstoppable
bind on the king's side yes white still
looks very solid but here's what could
happen let's say white trades on H6
we're able then to get our Knight to G5
at that point we will be only two moves
away from setting up Unstoppable threats
remember that old friend King G7 and
Rook h8 well that's kind of what I'm
aiming toward C5 Jesus that I was
absolutely not even close to being on my
radar like I saw this possibility but I
didn't think you would play it here
guess it's a good move I don't know
and if we take take and go Queen H6 here
at that point the pawn structure gets
really bad for white so that is very
attractive to me
very attractive
yeah we're not resisting oh but Knights
but Knight takes C4 my gosh it gets
complicated let's take
and queen H6 why Queen H6 and not Queen
G5 because we want to reserve the G5
Square for our night are am I sure that
we're going to go Knight G5 of course
not the position is highly unpredictable
but you have to set yourself up for
success
now we've created concrete weaknesses in
White's position that are easy to attack
the drawback of course is that we've
given white the f file why don't I care
about that because I feel like there's
nothing on the f file for white now
we're looking for some tactics I'm
looking at the Rook I'm also looking at
this D3 Square I think we can play DC
well we definitely should play DC anyway
regardless of what we're doing next
and after Queen C5 we have a forkovich
on D3 and suddenly White's position
showing some signs of weakness what's
funny is we might actually refrain from
playing Knight D3 because
there's a case to be made that this
Knight on E5 is such a strong piece that
it's not worth winning the exchange for
it so after Queen takes C5 it's it's
probably worth considering the move
Knight to G5
so strong is our Knight but probably we
will in fact play Knight D3 I don't
think I can resist the temptation to win
The Exchange
okay our opponent does not take on C5
seeing Knight T3
okay
so what happens now well our Queen is
hanging and as I mentioned earlier
Bishop takes F5 comes with a very steep
price tag after e takes F5 white gets
the E4 Square for their Knight but at
this point the circumstances have
changed our Queen is no longer on F6 so
the move Knight E4 is no longer going to
come with Tempo so how do we set
ourselves up for the possibility of 94.
well I definitely think we should take
this Knight I don't think that we should
let this Knight exist on F5 and now I
think we should go Knight G5 I think
this is the critical move
and largely Knight G5 is a prophylactic
move actually oh Knight F6 would have
been nice
oh man I completely forgot about that
Knight F6 would have been awesome
I forgot about Knight F6
Knight G5 is a stubborn move right this
is what I always wanted to play
so I still think it's a good move
because we have the prospect now of
playing Knight H3 check forcing the
exchange of Bishop for Knight and the G3
Pawn is going to be super weak and the
other night is threatening to jump into
F3 the suddenly White's position I think
is starting to crumble
and it can crumble really really fast
because we're not even done we can bring
our Rook over to d8 and intensify the
pressure down the center Knight C4
it feels like our opponent is crumbling
but we have to be Uber precise in our
execution here and what that involves is
deciding which Knight we want to put on
F3
I think it should be Knight E to F3 but
I'm not sure
Knight E to F3 King F2 Knight H3
yes I'm pretty sure
that we should play an idf3 here oh wait
yeah okay that that's kind of this is
all predicated on one very like flimsy
line that I just calculated and maybe I
should have spent longer
but I'm pretty sure that black is
winning
Maybe not maybe not it's gonna get super
tactical here which is why I'm really
happy we left ourselves with a lot of
time
okay so here critical moment I think a
lot of you are tempted by the move Queen
H2 that's a terrible move for many
reasons but one of which is Rook takes
G4 and suddenly the Knight on G5 is
pinned so we have an opportunity train
that we need to jump on right now
because we will not get another chance
to play this move and the move I'm
talking about is night H3 check
we stick that night in there before it's
too late forcing white to take it
otherwise we capture The Rook then we
take back with a queen and I didn't see
a defense for white in that position I
think we're just winning on the spot
here we're threatening to win White's
Queen with Queen H2 you should see that
that's a skewer but Queen H2 is a
standalone threat even if it didn't win
White's Queen it would lead to a mating
attack
I'm pretty sure that white has no
defense here but maybe he'll find
something with his last seconds Rook
takes F3 by the way we still go Queen H2
we don't actually recapture The Rook
which is
problematic for white because I don't
think white is a move man if we can
finish this one off that this would be a
really nice game I would be proud of
this one
if if we're able to drive this one home
because this just shows you how
versatile and Rich of an opening the
king's Indian is and in how many
different ways you can win a game in the
king's Indian but let's count the
chickens when they've hatched no our
opponent actually played a very good
game I think the mistakes came at the
very but wait all of this is a moot
point let's actually win but the win
here plays itself what we need to do is
drive the white king out into the center
and then deliver a decisive check with a
rook on d8 this is done with a zigzag
mechanism that you should be familiar
with you check on H2 you check on G1 you
staircase the queen to G2 the king is
driven out to the Target Square where it
is picked off by The Rook notice that
white has no threats down this diagonal
so we have nothing to worry about we
just deliver the checks and it's a moot
point anyway because white isn't able to
Garner a Tempo Rook 88 all pieces are
participating in the attack in what is
likely to be the final position of the
game unless our opponent gives us the
chance to deliver mate
and resigns
nice game okay our highest rated
opponent in the speedrun there's a lot
to talk about I won't bore you to death
of the opening Theory but definitely a
lot of context to
to formulate
I'm gonna pull up chess base just so I
can um
make sure I'm not lying to you when it
comes to Theory
yeah super fun game and a lot to explore
I'm sure a lot of mistakes were made by
both of us it's impossible not to win
games this complex so we're going to
skip directly to the critical position I
won't you know explore the theory of the
other lines here if you look at gawaine
Jones's chessable course you can explore
C5 here which I think is maybe
objectively the best move at some point
Knight C6 and A6 was all the rage
um as it was also against the same ish
but not as much anymore Knight bd7 got
more popular uh in the last couple of
years at some point this fell out of
favor entirely so White Castles black
plays E5 of course E4 is not White's
only move the other main alternative is
Queen C2 and here you're supposed to
play 84 and Knight B6 very tricky line
that you've probably seen me playing
extensively in Blitz
um but there's definitely enough to
enough to talk about in the in the E4
line so again the other line that I've
played is e takes D4 and Knight C5 which
which does get a very classic Pawn
structure and I've I've experienced this
Pawn structure from the black side
for the majority of my chess career I
feel like I know the ins and outs of
this structure and all of the Maneuvers
and what makes it so interesting is that
the engine is always skeptical in this
structure about Black's chances it's
always 0.6 or 0.8 and that dissuades a
lot of people from going into it but you
can trust me that White's position is
exceedingly hard to play properly
because there are so many tricks there's
just so many everything here and Black's
pieces have so much potential that I
truly believe that from a practical
standpoint you know this structure is
very much worthwhile or for black I have
one countless quick games in this
structure with uh just an endless amount
of Tricks here's just one quick example
completely different opening but you'll
see the parallel
so this is a game that I played against
a very decent play like 1860. and this
was not San Francisco this was Reno I
don't know why okay this is ticking me
off let me say this is Reno okay so
here's what happens
um
he plays
in English
and we reached this structure right I
play the Kings Indian it's a fan ghetto
English
at first I played the Knight c6a6 plan
and we reached the structure right not
exactly the same thing but but it's
defined by the Pawns in E4 and CFA Now
watch how quickly his position collapses
Knight D7 and Knight C5 typical night
before and already he makes the losing
move here Knight D4 who can tell me why
this is a losing move he's trying to
contest the square on seasick completely
forgetting why I put the knights on B4
and C5 yeah this is a chess base the new
theme
because I said it was very good nicely
done
what does black do here Knight D3 which
Knight well not the one that's guarding
C6 because this would walk into a fork
rather you play Knight CD3 interfering
between the queen and the Knight and
attacking The Rook but white goes Knight
C6 deflecting in turn my knight but
after the trade I take this very
important Pawn on B2 and White's
position collapses then I went back to
B4 took another Pawn got my Bishop out
and then brought my queen over to B2 and
he resigned so I can show you a million
games like that where White Center
collapses really quickly and this isn't
even a line that happened in the game so
let's get to the actual matter at hand
which is the move C6 the older move so
white plays H3 which is standard fare in
this line the idea is to prepare Bishop
E3 and take away the G4 Square uh from
black snide and you know potentially
even from the light squared Bishop still
Mainline Theory H3
and now the move Queen A5 so as I
explained earlier there are broad level
points to this move and then there are
like the specifics the queen on A5 is a
very powerful piece because it's
attacking from the side it has the
prospect of driving over to H5 which
does happen in a line that I'm about to
show you and sometimes it can even move
into B4 which is a surprisingly
problematic move for white to face so
let's explore some lines and hopefully
these lines will not only contextualize
this line but kind of start to give you
an understanding of why I really like
this line and how tricky it is white
again has a way to get an advantage
several ways actually but this requires
not only vast theoretical knowledge but
knowledge of all of blacks tricks and
all of White's key ideas let's
examine some lines the main move here is
to play rookie one this is the main move
and my computer is going to be a little
loud here just warning you in response
to rookie1
you play e takes D4 Knight takes D4 and
Knight E5 and here you see idea number
one the fundamental purpose of putting
the queen on A5 white cannot play B3
because he drops C3 and it's hard to
defend the C4 Pawn if white tries to do
it with his Queen okay if y tries to
play Queen E2
who can tell me actually not who can
tell me well who can tell me a way to
Fork the Knight on D4 and the pawn on
C4 who can see the move
Bang Bang
there is another reason you put the
queen on A5 and in order not to be worse
white has to play a bunch of engine
moves like if Bishop E3 then you already
win the pawn and black has a great
position White's supposed to go Rook D1
which is a kind of a hard move to come
up with
and here the position gets very wild you
play Knight takes C4 and amazingly white
is unable to separate the queen from the
Knight like white can try Knight B3 but
after Queen B4
Rook D4
um the Knight can be effectively
defended with either Bishop E6 or even
B5
and black is already better at this
point
so this is one easy way to lose the pawn
for that reason most people
traditionally go Bishop F1 here this is
the main line of course this takes the
sting out of the move Queen C5 because
that no longer well technically Queen C5
does hit the Knight that's funny but
here white has the move Knight B3 and
you can't take the pawn so Queen C5 is
futile for that reason you improve your
position with Rook to E8
in the main line white completes his
development with Bishop E3 and so do we
and I've already shown this line in a
previous speedrun game in this position
tons of people walk into a beautiful
tactic I've won tons of games like this
in Blitz I've even won an important
rapid game with this trick and it's only
karpov blunder this in a classical game
in which he played the move A3 against
Pia cromlink preparing B4 who can
remember the beautiful trick of bolts
from the blue if there ever was one and
here the true reason for placing the
queen on A5 is revealed Knight takes C4
what the heck is the idea Knight takes
C4 If instead white plays B4 very
importantly you take the Knight and hit
the queen that's a critical detail
Queenie one
look at this Queenie one
Queen E1 and because white played Bishop
back to F1 the weakness of F3
is what kills him Knight F3 check Knight
takes Queen and everything works out
perfectly because the Knight is hanging
so when you count the material you find
that white is down in exchange if white
plays Knight G5 then you evacuate your
knight with Tempo Rook C1 Knight takes
C3 Knight E6 Knight F1 Knight G7 Knight
D2 and the White Knight is trapped but
even if it wasn't trapped you could just
play Knight takes G3 and King takes G7
with two extra pawns so this is just an
extra credit line but still very very
cool
obviously okay if white takes the night
then you also take the Knight with an
extra piece dude that's the easy line
so that is the gist of this line if
white knows about the trick Knight takes
C4 it's still not that easy to figure
out a way to defend against it because
you can't play Queen D2 that walks right
into the fork does anybody know
worldwide's best move in this position
is
it's a prophylactic move which does I
wouldn't say it kills the lion but it
casts a lot of Doubt on this line it is
King G2 the best move and most modern
day GMS know this is to play King G2 and
permanently prevent the possibility of
Knight F3
earlier people would play F4 and chase
this Knight out of E5 you can actually
sack the Knight with Knight takes E4
here and I'm pretty sure that we did
have a speedrun game that went exactly
like this from a practical standpoint
this is a great line for black white
plays F6 C5 if Knight takes Knight then
Queen takes E1 still works because it
hits the bishop
but after fe5 Knight G3 White's position
is exceedingly difficult to play why
because you're about to pick up a third
part and if white plays e takes D6
there's yet another beautiful tactic who
can tell me
how we continue the initiative in this
position if you're watching on YouTube
make sure to pause the video This is
actually a crucial resource without this
resource the whole line would fall apart
the king's Indian is often predicated on
tactics to make everything work in the
end
it's Rook takes Bishop Rook takes rook
and now it's Bishop D4 right no that
button is the bishop so how do we pin
this Rook we play Queen C5 and again the
queen on A5 makes its presence felt
Queen C5 pinning The Rook well white has
to defend the Rook how does he do it
well if he does it with Queen to D2 and
the Knight drops back to F5 and Black's
got way too many attackers on that Rook
white can play Rook a to E1 but now you
simply play Knight takes E3
if Queen takes E3 then we win the queen
and if Rook takes E3 we play Bishop H6
hitting where it hurts white again has
to defend the Rook with the Knight
Knight D1 and now we play it simple we
just take the Rook
we play Rook d8 we pick up the pawn and
we have a winning position because we've
got the overwhelming majority on the
king side and White's got the long-term
problems with the King it's about minus
two
so instead of Queen to D2 white has to
know the move Queen D3 Which is far from
intuitive and black is still better
Bishop D4
Rook ae1
Knight F5 continuing to apply pressure
with everything that we've got white
continues to defend with everything that
they've got but after Knight takes C3
Knight takes E3 Rook d8 I think that
practically Black's position is better
the engine gives complete equality here
King moves away we play Rook takes D6
and here my file ends
with the comment that black has
fantastic practical compensation for the
sacrificed piece in the form of two
pawns which very likely will become
three pawns because white has no good
way to defend the B uh the B2 Pawn now
if for example white plays B3 the queen
swings over to G5 with the threat of
Queen G3 the threat of Bishop E5 etc
etc and this is after White's finish to
find all of these moves so I know these
are very technical long lines I know I'm
probably
and you know I've lost some people but
for that reason about 10 years ago this
move King G2 was discovered and it
really removed the luster of this line
at like the very top level but at really
any level below 2400 you can play this
safely and the black's position is still
very much playable so even if white
knows the move King G2 I analyze this
with an engine and the best move here is
to actually push H5 and prevent the
further expansion of White's King side
generally white plays F4
and after Knight 87 I don't think that
white is much better here honestly I
think the position's close to equal
um because if white plays Bishop D3 then
the Knight reroutes to C5 which is quite
typical in the kidneys India F4 believe
it or not is an inaccuracy so white
needs to be more patient but it's not
easy for white to find a plan like if
white plays Queen to D2 you drop back on
your own power Knight 87 attacking the
pawn forcing a weakening move such as F3
and now you play against White's dark
squares you play H4 G4
and who can tell me a very deep
positional move that enables us to
prepare to increase our control over the
dark squares on the king's side
I'll give you a second
it's 9h7 it's Knight H7 again X Glenn
Knight H7
and the point of this move
is to prepare the move G5 and this is
very similar to what we did in the game
once you play G5 why does stock saddled
with all these dark Square weaknesses on
the king side and if white ever plays F4
to try to beat the Curve
um if white ever plays F4 to try to beat
the curve then black plays Bishop takes
C3 and the E4 Pawn will be lost and with
the E4 Pawn White's hole position starts
to crumble BC Knight df6 you're gonna
take the pawn on the Knight and black
has a big initiative
so from again what I'm trying to show
you not only is how to play this line
from a theoretical standpoint but also
to show you just the the gumption
inherent in this king's Indian line no
matter how white how accurately white
plays there's always going to be
practical problems
so that is the lowdown on the main line
unfortunately in this game white played
a very annoying move there's two
annoying lines that really come close to
taking the queen A5 variation out of
commission and one of them is Bishop E3
the other one is this move Queen to C2
um and if I were to make a
recommendation for white it would be
Queen C2 I really think that this move
casts a lot of Doubt on on this
variation because if black plays it the
same way as the the rookie one line then
white simply plays B3 and none of the
tricks work in this position like
literally none of them
so my conclusion is that Black's best
move is to expand with B5 which leads to
a very sharp line but white is better in
the end like B5 I think the line goes
d-e-d-e
and still like black can absolutely play
this because if white plays cbcb already
I think black is fine I think here the
position is close to equal unless white
knows a very difficult move which is to
meet black at the top with B4 white has
to know this move in order to gain an
advantage in this line otherwise black
bushes before and puts a lot of pressure
on the E4 Pawn by fianchettoing the
bishop
the point of B4 is to play Rook B1
black drops around to C4 and white
develops a pretty annoying initiative
with the move Bishop A3 basically
White's Making a lot of tempo moves and
bringing the other Rook to C1 and black
needs to tread very very carefully here
okay
so
finally the move in the game is another
reason why this line is not all that
often played at the top level I played
he takes D4 and our opponent responds
with Bishop takes D4 what you need to
know about this line
is that I think the best move is in fact
Knight 64. and do not play Knight E5
here because here after Queen E2 again
none of the tricks really work for black
if you try to play this the same way
that you play the rookie one variation
white will put the Rook on D1 this is
actually the positional point of Bishop
E3 white is delaying the development of
The Rook so that in the event of Queen
rookie white will be able to play Rook
fd1 and apply pressure on the D6 Pawn
so for instance if you play Bishop E6
white trades on E6 and The Rook on D1 is
placed so much better than the Rook on
E1 here white has a very instructive and
Incredibly powerful positional move
let's see if anybody can find it I'll be
pretty impressed this is a very hard
move white to play and gain a decisive
initiative and it's not F4 we already
know that F4 is almost never all that
dangerous
I know most of you are probably thinking
it's F4 and the idea is predicated on
playing F4 but you have to do something
first you strike at the C yeah you
strike at the D file first C5 and only
when black takes in the D file is opened
do you push F4 and E5 driving a massive
wedge into Black's position with
potentially decisive effects in order to
not lose a piece black has to play this
miserable move Knight D5 and just look
at this position like White's whites
winning Rook 81 is coming Black's pieces
are in shambles this is a disaster
so that actually is the point of Bishop
E3 you see how deep it is
for this reason I came to the conclusion
that the only way to keep this line
alive is to play the move Knight to B6
again just hitting the pawn same concept
just doing it from the Dip from a safer
side and black is worse here black is
worse but you can play this white has to
know Knight B3 hitting the queen and now
you swing the queen over to the other
side the second main idea of the move
Queen A5 is shown in this line This
basically forces an end game because if
white plays G4 then of course black will
play Bishop to hg4 and develop a massive
attack as well as three pawns for the
piece because you're gonna pick up C4
um so why does to trade queens and
the engine gives about 0.5 per white but
I really feel like again Black's
position is very much playable here
white is supposed to go G4
you drop the Knight back to F6 and if
white defends the C4 Pawn then obviously
you bring your Bishop out to E6 and you
could play H5 later you could push D5
I've had this a couple times online and
people really don't show anything here
with white
so that is the Lowdown from a
theoretical standpoint now let's get to
the text and let's enter the middle game
our opponent plays Bishop takes D4
okay so I'm seeing something very
interesting with the engine
which is that apparently 95 is possible
here
it's possible and it's even the top
engine move but I don't like the ensuing
position
so apparently after C5 black can play
the very cold-blooded Knight F6 back to
E8 now obviously it's generally not a
great idea to trade the king's Indian
Bishop but When the Smoke Clears you get
a very playable position for black
slightly worse for sure yeah slightly
worse but very much playable you're
going to bring your Bishop out you can
centralize your queen white really
doesn't have all that much to write home
about but somehow I was under the
impression that C5 almost wins the game
so I decided to delay that move with
Rook to E8 okay Rook to E1 Queen C7
top engine move here is Knight H2 by the
way crazy
how many times has the move Knight H2
and Knight H7 been a good move in this
game for both sides pretty ridiculous
do you see anybody ever going Knight H2
I mean that's just crazy
do you know what the idea is I think I
understand the idea the idea is
to make sure that this move does not
make contact with the Knight it's
prophylaxis it's prophylaxis you're
talking the Knight away so that after
black plays 95 you can simply go B3 and
this Knight is not contacting any of
White's pieces
right obviously if you do the same thing
here Black's Knight has an out it can
play Knight takes F3 check
so you're moving the Knight away
preemptively okay our opponent plays
Queen C2 we played Knight E5 and Knight
D2 I think is a very strong move
I've shown you guys a lot of examples of
mine in this structure I've shown you
probably three or four games at least
where I was able to win
straightforwardly by getting a knight
and putting it on D4 like doing this
Knight D7 f8064.
one example that I really really am
proud of
is a game I had I think in 2008 let me
see if I can dig it up real quickly this
is a game that I had many years ago
against Eric Rodriguez who was a master
from Miami
and he
Eric Rodriguez was like a
D4 stalworth so it was nice to beat him
at his own game
okay let me just make the board a little
smaller here
all right
so here's how the game went this was a
king's Indian it was a main line
my opponent quickly trades on E5
reaching the same structure that we're
talking about it doesn't matter where
this bishop is it can be on G2 community
so it does not change the nature of the
way that the structure works and I just
followed the textbook Knight H5 Knight
F4 Knight E6 right you're already ready
to sink the teeth of this Knight into D4
which is exactly what I did I played
rook d8 and I played Knight T4 and
White's position is already miserable
then who can tell me where should the
other night go where does the Knight on
A6 belong in order to buttress the
Knight on D4 easy positional question
easy positional question
yeah E6 right you want to go Knight C7
and 96 simple chess making sure that
this Knight is as stable as it can be
and the rest of the game I developed
some pressure on his B4 Pawn so it's not
enough to put a knight on D4 you also
have to do other stuff in order to
continue keeping your opponent on his
toes A4 Knight D4 now the other Knight
comes in
Bishop developed ultimately he was able
to trade the Knight but the pawn on D4
is a beast
and then I was able to win the game
the rest of the game is outside of the
scope of why I'm showing you this but
ultimately I had some really nice
maneuvers
it wasn't a perfect game but at the end
of the day the d-pawn was the decisive
pawn and this is the pawn that was
spawned no pun intended by the move
Knight D4
so let's go back to the game
continuation
hopefully this makes sense
so the takeaway is that this structure
is almost always very unappetizing for
white with some minor exceptions and
your next move is going to be Knight f8
and 96. hopefully that makes sense so
our opponent made a very mature move
Knight T2 of course if white plays B3
this is what we were talking about
earlier black is able to take on F3 and
take on H3 so this is out of the
question so this only leaves Knight D2
G5 I actually am really proud of this
move I think G5 is a big reason why we
won this game the play that I
demonstrated on the king side and yes
yes I'm sure that black is worse here
maybe even plus over minus but that's
what the king's Indian is all about and
I think our opponent one of his main
mistakes in this game was maybe to play
a little bit slowly although what he did
initially I think is really really
strong I think the way our opponents set
things up with B3 and Rook D1 is really
well done like he's bringing all of his
pieces into the center everything is
nicely coordinated and I actually think
I actually am convinced that a big
mistake was to play hdhg4 believe it or
not I actually think this Supernatural
move is a mistake which what do I think
white should have done and why who can
tell me an alternative
and I just checked with the engine white
kept a big Advantage but only
by playing this other move H4 why what
is the difference between H4 and H takes
G4 the difference is very positional
it's subtle
first of all the H file is Frozen that's
a big deal but that's not the main
reason you play H4 the main reason has
to do with restricting the Knight on F6
this prevents the Knight H7 Knight G5
idea that essentially cost quite the
game
okay so the Knight on F6 dies and this
Pawn chain is able to keep all of Lex
kingside pressure at Bay whereas in the
event of this trade we were able to get
the Knight to G5 and in the end of the
game we were able to use the H file to
develop a decisive attack this is what
these games come down to these subtle
positional moments the computer
evaluation here is plus 1.5 Black's
position is bad
and what are some ideas that white can
subsequently have well this 92 Knight F4
maneuver I think is particularly strong
because the H5 font is a long-term
Target so the engine gives B5 as a way
to try to generate counter play which is
another idea that you should always be
aware of as a king's Indian player B7 B5
the point is that if white takes the
Queens are in a standoff and White's
Queen is undeveloped is undefended
so after B5 white just has to
cold-blooded cold-bloodedly respond with
Knight E2 and the engine line goes
Bishop A6
now white continues with their plan
Knight F4
BC Knight C4
now obviously the 995 is the pride and
joy of Black's position so you don't
want to give it away you take with a
bishop BC
and Black's position is just a stinking
mess White's got more space White's got
C5 White's got pressure on H5
I don't see a clear idea for black yeah
you've got a nice Knight on E5 congrats
but one nice piece isn't going to save
you
so what's interesting is that if we
rewind and we ask well where was my
mistake
yeah probably G5 was a mistake from an
objective standpoint if White had played
the correct him of H4 black would have
been in serious trouble positionally
um and I I admit that and I saw H4 I
just figured we'd figure something out I
think this was the turning point in the
game
so instead our opponent plays hghg and
then 92 and this makes all of the
difference this move Knight H7 it's the
top engine move and this is an equal
position because of this Knight G5 idea
okay so our opponent plays Bishop E3 to
prevent Knight G5
and now we reinforce the idea with Queen
E7 preparing Knight G5 this was in fact
the correct move well red hot mama was
asking if the king side gets locked with
H4 can't you convert to a queen side
attack well that's exactly what I was
trying to do with the move B5 the
problem is that the C4 Pawn is so well
protected white can just completely
ignore like I would not play CB if I
were white and allow black to generate
counter play down the C file I would
just ignore with Knight E2
um Luca was proposing Knight fd7 Knight
f8 in 96 yeah it's possible but even if
the Knight gets to E6
even if the Knight gets to E6 well what
is it doing there The Bishop's just
gonna drop back
so according to the computer let's see
what the computer gives here 92 98
Knight F4 Knight E6 oh wow look at this
line Knight f496
calmly Bishop C3 allowing Knight takes
F4 and Knight G6 but white is winning
here Bishop takes G7 King takes G7
F5 apparently is the move
now Knight takes H4 is bad because the
Knight will get stranded and after 95
white pushes F4
pushing the other doubled pawn and
essentially Black's King is terrible and
the bishop on C8 is biting on granite so
in the long run Black's King is just not
going to survive the onslaught what
White's gonna do here is essentially
move the king over to H1 and use the G
file to blast through
even if black puts a knight on G4 still
King H1 Rook G1 and Bishop H3 totally
Unstoppable because Black's Bishop is
never going to be able to get out of the
prison the prison created by these two
Pawns engines just think I mean who
would have played like who would play
like this giving up the E5 square and
then pushing to the other F Pawn and it
all starts to make sense at the end so
that's the way that you refute metaphate
96. okay so back we go to the game Queen
E7 Knight T4 Queen F6
Rook F1 I think might be a subsequent
mistake after which black is better
and Bishop H6 top move
I think that white had to go Knight F5
here our opponent started hesitating
because I think he was sensing that the
position was getting worse but I think
white should play Knight F5 although I
don't know what white should do here I
feel like white is out of concrete
threats the engine gives King H2 which
is not a human move oh the idea is Rook
H1 and King G1 okay kind of is Rook H1
and King G1 is the idea
so here
wow what a line
look at this line black plays Bishop F5
EF and Bishop H6 now who can tell me why
does this look like a blunder
or at the very least a very inadvisable
move
why does Bishop H6 look like an
inadvisable move it's because of Knight
E4 but watch these tactics Queen takes
F5
Bishop takes H6 Queen H5 using the
position of White's King to our
advantage then we take the bishop but
white not to be outdone recaptures on D6
and the position is equal according to
the engine apparently this is an equal
position but I would definitely take
black just because we have such
potential of getting the Knight to G3 G5
and then F3 White's pieces are kind of
hanging suspended in midair but
objectively the position is about equal
at this point after Rook F1 white is
already worse because we get this move
in and we're able to trade dark scored
Bishops which leaves white with a
terrible Bishop on G2 and this idea of
Knight G5
is an absolute Game Changer Knight H7
was the game-winning move here so our
opponent kind of resorts to desperation
I think probably C5 was another mistake
but not a big one
I think the biggest mistake our opponent
made in this position was to play Knight
F5 I think after Knight F5 the game is
close to over I think it's close to over
what should white have done well without
thinking white should have played Queen
takes C5 and this is I think a Grand
Master Level observation because why
once black plays Knight C3 99 of players
would reject this line you would see
Knight D3 you see that you lose the
exchange and you think that's losing but
the Grand Master would keep calculating
here's what I see after Queen C2 Knight
takes F4 well no Queen C2 Knight F4 ef4
if you look deeply at this position you
start to realize that white has massive
massive compensation for the exchange
first of all White's Pawn structure on
the king side has been rectified that's
a big plus but white has a specific idea
that allows them to maximize the
activity of the minor pieces while also
restricting Black's Knight what is
likely to be White's next move pause the
video if you're watching on YouTube ask
yourself what White's next move is going
to be so for instance the engine gives
Bishop E6 as the top move
it's gonna be E5 to restrict the Knight
and open up a massive Square for the
Knight so for example Rook Ada you drop
the Knight into E4 that Knight can
further go on to D6 Black's position is
already unpleasant
Black's position is already quite
unpleasant here
and apparently the correct line is to
play F6 weakening the bishop white can
grab it and play Queen C4 fv5 F5 and you
have a Perpetual check
Perpetual check with Queen H6 Queen E3
this is how the game should have ended
so actually after Queen takes C5 the
hilarious thing is Knight D3 is wrong in
order to keep an advantage Black's best
bet is to play a simple move like B6 and
chase this queen away
and after Queen C2
for whatever reason the best move is B5
wow B5
who can tell me why what is the point of
B5
you play B6 to chase the queen away
that's understandable why is the best
move B5
such an instructive positional move its
prophylaxis again
you stop Knight C4 why is it so
important to stop 94 because that would
trade off Black's strongest piece the
Knight on E5 is what makes Black's
position run
okay so if you rush with Knight G5 white
plays Knight C4 and once this Knight
disappears The C6 Pawn becomes weaker it
becomes harder to attack therefore you
cover the two squares from which white
can trade that Knight off C4 and F3
so prophylaxis even in very sharp
positions can be a thing but our
opponent panics he played Knight F5 and
this is the beginning of the end I think
Knight F6 was more accurate but I think
Knight G5 does the job as well and
Knight C4 loses on the spot
um to to net F3 check apparently the
only way to keep some chances alive was
the very difficult move Knight to E4
but black is still in fantastic shape we
can take on e4 we can slide the queen
over to F6 to prevent white from playing
F6 and gaining activity then we bring
the Rook into d8 look at that monster
Knight look at White's weaknesses this
is minus over plus
so instead Knight c490 F3 check
you might ask why not with the other
night because here after King F2 the
Knight on E5 is super awkward it's not
doing anything instead if we check with
the other Knight then the knight from G5
can jump into H3 so look at the
cooperation between the knights here if
White had played King to F1 then we
should not play Queen H2 because of
Queen F2 and suddenly Black's Queen is
stuck in no man's lead instead we should
use the center to our advantage we
should play Rook 88 and black is
completely winning notice that white
cannot take on H4 G4 because of this
Fork if white plays Bishop F3 you take
on F3 you slide the king over to f8 and
much like in the game all these threats
are unstoppable so this is very simple
King F2 and Knight H3 check removing the
final Defender
and once the final Defender is removed
the threats against White's King have
become completely Unstoppable we zigzag
our way to G2 and pick off and finish
off the king with Roketa dhek a final
move involves the first move we make
with the Rook which I think is kind of
artistic cool what a game
so a couple of concluding thoughts first
of all I introduced you to my favorite
line against the fiancaro
we kept our analysis to the E4 variation
let me be very clear white has a million
Alternatives here you know there's
Bishop G5 there's Queen C2 which I
briefly mentioned there's E3 there's B3
if you can't play the finquet on the
basis of this game alone you can but you
have to study it more diligently but
that would be way way too much so C6 and
queen A5 hopefully I was able to really
bring out the beauty of the placement of
this queen on A5 we focused on a lot of
theory we looked at rookie one in depth
we looked at Queen C2 there's other
moves there's the move D5 and here you
take take and go B5 expanding on the
queen side won't talk about this one
then we analyze Knight takes D4 so we
did some Theory
and then of course we talked about the
middle game Knight D2 was a very nice
move
I like this idea of G5 but the turning
point in the whole game came in this
position and I always say that when we
reach a higher level in the speedrun the
games what decides the games the margins
are thinner and thinner and thinner what
decides the games are much less blunders
then you hit like 16 1700s and it's
still big tactical moments that decide
the game or like massive positional
mistakes when you hit this level it's
the subtlest it's the most nuanced
moments that really decide the game and
when I say decide the game I don't mean
lose H takes G4 is not a losing mistake
but it gives black a very easy game and
all of white subsequent troubles stemmed
from the fact that white did not play H4
I think that's a fascinating aspect of
Chess that things can come down to think
to such a level of subtlety so hopefully
you enjoyed the game I know this was
very Advanced a lot of theory I worked
really hard to give you as much as I
could I hope you enjoyed the game
and uh I'm gonna end here guys because
this was very very taxing and I tried
super super hard
I tried super hard to uh to play my best
I mean we played at 2400. thank you
thank you guys for hanging out today
five hour stream a lot of Blitz a lot of
bullet a lot of action a lot of fun
thank you everybody
[Music]